i'm mr lomasi i am a twitch streamer i
have been playing diablo 2 for 20 years
streaming it for six years
i probably have over 25 000 hours in
this game and
just absolutely love it so seeing the
remaster
happen i have to just of course ask a
very first high-level question
why the detourie master right now well
diablo 2 is a very special game to
blizzard
as many of you well know and diablo 2
also had its 20th year anniversary so
with that we we really wanted to
stay true to what that authentic
experience was
for diablo 2 and bring it to the current
audience and
improve it for the existing audience and
invite new people to
experience it for the first time it's
also good learning opportunities too for
us
especially when we're partnering up with
vicarious visions now to
work on on a remastered projects like
this together so it's been a great
partnership
we've actually worked with blizzard for
a while now um
a couple years uh even starting with
some battle net integration type
things uh we just finished uh tony hawk
remaster
uh before that we did crash bandicoot
remasters and it just seemed like a
perfect match for us to work together it
was a shock
to my to my system to first to to come
in
and then see that it's a remastered
trailer i was not expecting that
uh but then to see the complete shift um
in the design and the art and everything
and i'd really love to hear
more about how you came up with the
process or
what how you want to remaster the look
of it right
how you wanted it to visually exist
and i'd love to bring in chris amaral to
talk about some of that
chris can you discuss a little bit of
the philosophy and the design
design decisions around this remaster
so luckily we had a ton of like good
inspiration from the original d2r
our primary focus is always nostalgia
right we want to make sure we focus on
getting this right
and deliver an authentic experience that
players remembered from 20 years ago
every choice we make with the art with
the models with the environments
should really ignite that nostalgia uh
and then reinforce that emotional
connection
from the original game but then we came
out and came up with like a 70 30 visual
guide
70 is basically the classic this is
where we don't touch we don't touch
what works right you want to maintain
those iconic shapes
colors tones everything should be one to
one and
faithful to the original we want things
to feel authentic
and preserve those original designs with
the 30 new like that's kind of like
where we're going to elevate that art
every change we make should really
signify that step forward visually i
also noticed that the game was
3d and can you talk a little bit about
uh
the discussion or how you moved and some
challenges
moving from 2d to 3d well i mean
evolving from a 2d
sprite game like a 2d image game to a 3d
is very challenging
we basically had to write a complete new
um
pbr renderer so a physically based
renderer on top of
the old game logic it's difficult
because you're dealing with
you know models versus versus 2d sprites
where you have to basically write you
have you have
dynamic lighting you have dynamic vfx
like a lot of that is an additional
system that we have to work out on our
end
so the follow-up to that question i
suppose is i wasn't able to see any
items when i was watching that trailer
are all of the items also going to be
remastered all of the gems all of
every single piece of this and what
sorts of
flavor did you decide to add uh to that
artwork uh so everything is being redone
so we remodeled everything because
everything has a drop in the game so you
have your you have your
icon art and then you have your 3d space
art that flips right so we had to
basically model everything
um so what and as far as the inspiration
we actually were inspired by some
original documentation that we found
from
you know from blizzard north where there
was a huge you know word doc of like
where the original artists pulled
inspiration from so a lot of that was
like
very like you know historical landmarks
locations and very very much real world
referencing that was kind of where we
kind of pulled
pulled our inspiration as well we wanted
that that functional
design that the original art had
everything felt like it was
believable and that detail really does
help to give it some realistic
context and makes you feel more immersed
in the in the game like it makes you
feel like you're part of this world when
you can see every little buckle and
strap
i remember when we went to the tavern
and there was garlic hanging from
a beam and we're all like what's the
garlic
and then you know this is all full 3d
everything and then
they're like oh yeah there was garlic in
the old game we go back and it's like
four
white sprites and you're like holy cow
yeah
garlic and there's hams hanging and
everything so there was it was really
cool to see
like to see it almost for the first time
and it's funny because uh
the original sd like it was made in all
3d so we actually came across
a bunch of screenshots that were a
different camera like it wasn't the
isometric camera it was like either
marketing art or
something else or maybe just exploration
but there was
shots of that garlic in the original art
you just you could never really see it
in the in the in the pixel art but it
was there
so it was it was telling that they were
they were really trying to achieve
something very you know very grand with
this art i'm not gonna lie
i never knew that they had garlic
hanging in there i mean maybe maybe a
couple white sprites i thought there
were maybe candles or
who knows no clue but that makes me
excited to go look around now and just
like
explore all of the areas in the game
just to look at the new detail art and
see what well you'll see it now too
because also we have you know the one
new feature for
for the art on the art side of things is
the zoom camera um
so it you know it'll it'll help you get
in there and look at all the details
like i it was something that i really
felt strongly that like a lot of arpg's
that come out now all have a zoom
feature
so this will really get you up and close
and personal with like your armor
your weapons like everything the runes
another way to look at it too is
our legacy toggle feature where you can
flip back between the old visuals
of the game and our current visuals it's
not even just a simple art swap
it is really the old game running
underneath because like
chris was mentioning our new art engine
is
our graphics engine is running on top of
the game
and is mimicking what is running
underneath it's still following all the
same
data and rules and timings of everything
so
we are still being true to the that 25
frames per second of what the game is
underneath but
rendering it in a way that has more
frames per second yeah
i'd love to hear more about that
specifically because when i
go into diablo 2 i'm thinking 25
fps and like you said the game is built
on that
my faster casting my hit recovery my
all of this stuff is built on 25 fps
so how do you create a game at 60fps
so all of the logic and and how the game
talks with the server and everything
like that
runs on that cycle and that hasn't
changed
so we still have benchmarks in all of
our content
say for animations of when a hit frame
occurs how long it can recover
and all of that that all matches exactly
now it can run at a faster frame rate
and so modern games run on time not
frames
so we've done that but all of the logic
still runs on those same things so you
can wait for your breaks
to occur all of those things still
happen at the exact same
uh and that was through no small effort
but um
but it's super important right because
even if you can't
see it right away you feel it when it's
when it's different
um we've done that on lots of areas so
for example
the original game only had so many
sprites to render
your rotation so you'd have your
character and they're rendered out at so
many
angles and the monsters even less but
you could actually
walk at greater
directions right you have i think it was
64 different squares around you
that you would path to and you'd have
feet sliding we've increased that
so now there's more granularity
obviously it's 3d or character can run
straight
but underneath the hood i mean this is a
game made
back when the inspiration was tabletop
games and so the game is a grid
so it still respects that grid right
like
on the controller will still allow you
to move small amounts
um because you push the stick a little
bit but it's still you're either in a
run state or a walk state stamina is
still a thing you're still on a grid
like all of that logic once again
is all being driven by the old game um
that hasn't changed
uh rob was mentioning animation
animation is is also like it was very it
was very challenging because
you know you you only had a few of the
frame
frame counts basically to basically make
that animation so it wasn't like a
modern game where you have
tons of different uh keys to make it
very fluid animation
we had to really like maintain that
timing that pace
um the posing was uh was a big big um
uh focus for us too we wanted to get
those those iconic poses for each
character
um and then just align that silhouette
so continuing the talk of visuals
i want to talk about characters
cosmetics
how they look because i know something
that i love with diablo 2
is just putting on you know a scale male
putting on a full plate male putting on
a sacred armor and seeing the character
like have the different change
and all of that but some things still
don't like reflect over
in the color of it or whatnot right some
do some don't
is there going to be changes there or is
it just enhancing all of those visuals
and making them just look even cooler so
our goal was to basically
uh be one-to-one with parity with the
original game so we
we built every piece of armor that was
in the original game and is now in the
remastered version the only difference
we did is with
the icon items so we actually now we
have a more
connected uh visual with the icon and
the the item that drops in the game
where before you had you know you had
different visuals um
that's really the only thing we pushed
on as far as modernization
yeah so like shields or weapons a lot of
the unique items that you find in the
game had
special kind of icon arts right and that
is something we're actually
going to be showing on your character in
the new visuals that definitely excites
me i think that's something a lot of
people would love to see you know
a lance guard and have the cool stuff
actually on their character there
it will be the same model you see on
those icons are we going to see
remastering of the cinematics in the
game
yes yes we are yeah full the entire full
28 minutes or whatever is gonna be all
remastered
uh with new high fidelity art it's gonna
look amazing by the way
so will the sound in those also be
remastered
and any other sound in the game be
remastered all of the audio has been
remastered as well as we've added
additional
um you know surround sound features
there's more ambient there's more
effects going on it's just a richer
experience if you want to play with your
you know full setup however we
have to use that measured hand as well
with audio there's
just a lot of very very iconic sounds
that we really couldn't change right
like if you put a skull
into your inventory that pop noise
don't change my skull sound exactly
right so
so yeah so there are certain things
you're going to you know you'll hear
for like you you know your your
footsteps running will have some
variety when when the rain kicks in it's
gonna have a lot more depth when you go
to the jungle you'll hear a lot more
life in those you know trees um
but yeah there's just some sounds we
couldn't mess with right with
uh blizzard you know when we're creating
new games one of our
design philosophies is to what we call
find the fun and when we were looking at
d2 again
we very much felt like the fun is still
there so it's actually one of our
core pillars for diablo ii resurrected
specifically was to
keep the fun and keep it at its core and
because of that we're looking at it more
as a remaster at that point and like
what can we do uh based on what the
community wants or what
features naturally are necessary for for
making this game run on modern day
systems and things like that
i think also on we want to thank and
appreciate the fan base right this is uh
this is really a true nod to the
original game
we want to preserve that game and the
structure of that game as much as we can
and if we we
went with with the the remake it would
be a completely different game so i
think that was a reason why we chose
this
speaking you know from my experience or
from some of my community's experience
and uh the discussions we've had
we definitely felt like with diablo 2 a
remastered just seemed like the way to
go
because there's so many like you said
there's so many of those tiny details
within the game
that create overall when you add them up
create such a big part of the experience
of the game
and remaking that into a new game could
be a challenge
and could also be a challenge in keeping
the fun of the game in that way i kind
of look at it
a little bit like starcraft brood war
which also had a remaster
um and how it's like a lot of the paving
bugs
and the you know duds from the reavers
and all of these things in the game that
were kind of
awful are what make the game beautiful
and what make the game super balanced
and if you were to go and remake it
and remove some of those issues it would
change what the
how the whole entire game plays and so i
felt like with diablo 2
that's kind of the same idea right you
got to keep some of those
difficult details because then it ends
up creating uh
you know the overall experience that we
all know and love yeah we also felt that
like you know for a game during its time
back in 2000 you know
based on limitations or everyone was
still looking at strategy guides
or just limited internet um it led to
that kind of
uh typical game design you see where
there was a lot of mystery discovery
um so we we felt like that was another
part of like you know part of keeping
the fun which was to
maintain that that discovery of the game
as well
so speaking to maintaining
and possibly changing what are the
pieces that
did end up staying the same or if it's
easier to to explain the other way what
are the pieces that were really changed
to bring this remaster to life so at its
core we want us to still be the same
so right away things like
the balance the monsters you see on this
uh spawn rates
uh item drops and things like that are
the same
and what we're doing is trying to take
any of the rough edges you see
compatibility issues resolution issues
and obviously the art improving the arts
as well
um all these kinds of things you come to
know from a remastered but still
maintaining very much what the game is
so and when it comes to the features we
added
this is probably the biggest area where
we we scrutinize so much is
is this is this addition straying too
much
you know does it still create the same
gameplay experience and other things
like that
so uh things like a shared stash
we know people use mule characters right
and so adding a shared stash
we felt was the right choice when we
have we have a shared stash
we have a ships yes yeah oh thank god
now the way that the shared stash works
is there are rules right you can't
you can't have your ladder characters
mixing a stash with a non-letter
character
um and you can have your offline
characters
you know can't use your online but for
the most part we're like
people do this anyway with a mule
character so it's okay to give them this
feature
that is like the greatest feature that
you could add
because there's nothing worse than
opening up the game
going in dropping all your gg items to
mule them over because you've run out of
space
and then not being able to log back in
or the game's not created or it didn't
permanent time and losing all of your
gear
or trying to find someone to help you
transfer your gear over
because oh my gosh a shared stash is
amazing thank you so much that's such a
help
like i said maintain the core was a
thing but the other aspect of it was
to see where we can improve right so the
shared stash is one of them because we
saw it as a very
common concern especially around mewling
which people had workarounds anyway
right so that is one thing another
example is we are reimagining the ui
in the game with a new reimagined ui
we're still trying to stay very faithful
to what you've come to expect so you'll
still have the the classic globes on the
hudson screen
the skill icons the potion belts and all
that but we are reorganizing a little
bit
you know we're trying to integrate the
menu buttons and the stamina bars closer
together within the hud so it's built a
little bit cleaner and with naturally
with reimagining a ui
we have some liberties to add a few
things so going back to the information
i was talking about
a big thing we're doing on the character
screen is we're adding an advanced stats
screen as well
so we're going to be showing you all the
information
you get from items as well so you don't
have to do that kind of math with
like looking at each of your items and
calculating how much magic find you have
for example it'll
be like summarized right there for you
something that we've seen
already in a in a lot of mods where
they've gone ahead and taken that
information and created a little screen
so that's really nice to see
um that you guys are implementing that
as well because yeah i don't think
anybody
likes sitting sitting down and counting
up the magic find
of every specific item you know and all
of their charms and all of
everything to figure out what is the
number how much do i have
we've also added uh auto gold so
you can opt in it is a feature you can
turn off which is one of the things we
have to be careful
you know a handful of other things where
we're like if you want this you can turn
it on
but you can also keep it off this was
actually something that we started
looking into when we
were adding controller support there's a
lot of paths that we could have taken
with controller support
um obviously for controllers on console
which we're coming out on
but uh allowing the you know just plug a
controller in
for accessibility reasons for that might
be the way you want to play but it's a
pc first
uh experience like for example there's
you know there's still an inventory grid
there's still inventory tetris
that's core to what diablo 2 is right
taking that away
it starts to become you know something
different and i love that i think that's
the perfect way to really introduce it
because
you're going to have that split in the
community you're going to have half the
people who say
just give me auto gold it's 20 20. i
don't want to worry about
having to pick up every individual gold
stack but then you're gonna have the
opposite side of purists who go
don't touch this like that completely
changes my game experience
and you know if i'm speed running
through the game or playing through
whatever i want to be
able to go over and pick up the gold
stacks and take that time and that's
more a part of the diago 2 experience
for me
i want to jump back to features in a
second
but before we do you just brought up
console play
and i think i feel like we have to jump
into
console the decision for console and
how we're gonna kind of how you're gonna
make that work you already talked a
little bit about like auto gold
uh having that to be a little more
accessible but when i think of diablo 2
i think of a mouse
going and clicking everywhere how does
this work on a console
say it was to say it wasn't a challenge
would be a bold lie
um so there's a there's a couple things
for the most part
our the game thinks you're still using a
keyboard and mouse with a controller
that was almost a rule we kept
you know um that helped keep us on the
rails
because we didn't want to be sacrificing
once again that
that authentic experience but we did
want to
make it more accessible bring it to a
modern audience i mean there are people
who
were born after this game came out
that we want them to enjoy it and and
play it a lot of those people are used
to you know
just more modern titles that could use a
controller also from an accessibility of
just allowing you to plug in a
controller
um helps for for many other people to
get to enjoy the game
the biggest thing i think that we we are
the two big things we'll say
one is you're changing the way you play
the game from
being kind of an eye in the sky and
telling
your hero what to do by clicking on
areas to actually
being your character and directing them
so pathfinding is gone
right because you're doing the
pathfinding and things like that which
creates some very interesting things for
example
the sorceress teleport is meant to
teleport to
to wherever you click so in that area
when you're playing on the console we
will have
a kind of a default distance that you
will teleport to
whereas on the pc you can click wherever
you want
same with barbarians leap although that
one's interesting because it levels
but it's it's become a very very fun
challenge like
i'm a necromancer and i need to target
an item on the ground that has a certain
keyword
it's working so far but you guys will be
the ultimate judge of that
yeah we've had a lot of talks back and
forth play testing and things like that
um you know a good a big challenge we
had
two was categorizing you know all those
300 character skills
um to see how each of them really played
to see what challenges there were and
yeah like rob mentions that
the necromancer iron golem is a favorite
of ours to continuously talk about
because
the various ways you can target um also
like a sorceress telekinesis is another
example
watching the trailer uh we see the
assassin and druid at the campfire we
see a druid casting tornado
i have to ask though uh even still i'm
this includes lord of destruction right
this is going to be a full
encompassing remaster and not just
classic or just a piece
that's correct yeah we are we are going
to be including
both the base diablo 2 and
the expansion lord destruction as well
and we're even
uh keeping the mode of playing
non-expansion character
as well right so you could still play a
classic uh barbarian for example and
things like that
okay awesome because that was something
i was also going to ask was will there
be classic mode because like once again
when you go to the purist
you always have the people that go back
all the way and they're like classic is
pure
and that's it and i won't play anything
else yeah it was very much what we
wanted to keep
even based on popularity might not be as
much but it's still a part of the game
and uh it still leads to interesting
ways of playing too right
um a lot of it's even data driven too so
like a lot a lot of the reasons to keep
it were pretty clear to us like
let's let's make sure we're not taking
something away from this remaster
i'd love to go ahead and start talking
about some of the other features or
continue talking about some of the other
features
that you had mentioned before because
hearing each of these
already has gotten me so excited for
this game uh and so
what are some other little things that
you felt could be changed
wouldn't change the whole flow of the
game but just improve it a little bit
one thing we're looking into is uh
making it easier to interact with
your stash so having quick keys to move
to your stash
is is one thing versus like dragging the
mouse to every time you want to move
something to your stash
other things we're looking at as well
are like an item comparison tool tip so
in case you're looking at some other
item you can you can
hold shift or whatever controller button
is
mapped and then you can see what
equipped items you have just for quick
glances things like that
the item comparison is a great example
of us adding it but added it with a
measured hand
so we don't suggest any gear for anybody
the gear in diablo 2 is so quirky and
different and every class can use
everything that us
recommending things like that actually
was more confusing to people
so uh you literally you hold shift and
it's like here's what you got equipped
here's what it is
i think that's the great way to do it
with diablo 2 cause i agree i mean
that's
i think that's one of the best parts
about diablo 2. the items are so
fantastic
so unique in their own design that
it would be near impossible to have a
tool tip that can actually recommend
one or the other you know because it's
all so
unique to every situation and character
and skill build and everything
uh we added five more languages so
that's a feature to
a lot of people who speak those other
languages the whole
front end is pretty much modernized now
so your
your character is much bigger front and
center right in the in
in the beginning and you'll have a
backdrop of whatever act you're in
so that's all been streamlined you can
still you know play online or offline
but that flow has been improved
so what are your favorite changes uh
that each of you have
within the game so far uh there's a lot
of
fun it's it's fun to see a lot of the
art come to life with with our new
visuals so
for me one of the things i've been
waiting for since like
first starting on on this game was to
see that
character creation campfire scene come
to life in our in our new arts
and i'm i'm really happy to see how far
it's progressed and i love seeing that
it's just such an iconic moment it's the
first thing you really see in the game
before you get started
um and it's it's it's amazing can i see
all the art no i'm just kidding
uh so we added like robs that mentioned
we added like an act
specific screen in the front end um and
it's it's basically this la you know
large screen we have like a diorama
of each act and it's just it's amazing
to see because it feels like you're
really there like you can see the detail
you can see
every you know every aspect of the scene
and like it just has that
very immersive feeling to it so that's
probably my favorite part
i think mine is a little bit more more
squishy the
i think our game has gotten a little
scarier i think that there are certain
areas
in the game where um just the way that
the
you know the the 3d lighting is and the
way the sound is and
i play it on a big screen tv sometimes
and just
it it feels scarier it feels creepier
a little more claustrophobic in you know
certain areas that's not just one
feature there's a lot of things going on
there
but i think it's really really cool i
would like to hope that it's the
had the original creators had the tools
we have today
it's the experience they would have
wanted to make yeah i think the lighting
really helps with that too because we're
a 3d
game that's one of the biggest
differences between the original games
so
what the game had before with the
sprites
um with 3d models built into sprites was
not a a true real-time lighting system
so
because we're pushing that with a 3d
graphics engine running on top of the
game and getting actual 3d lighting
inside of those kinds of caverns and
corridors makes for a very
interesting uh experience now because it
just feels more immersive with
with having light react around you like
that yeah i would definitely say
i mean i've only seen the trailer piece
you sent me but even from that
just seeing like down in the tunnels or
the sewers
or you know any of those like like you
said cavern dungeness zones
the lighting it was darker and brighter
and then things like
the skeletons with the fire but it just
had like this
different i agree creepier feel so i
haven't seen
much more than or anything more than you
guys showed me but it there was
definitely a different
feel to the game and i loved the fire
the most i think just watching like the
sorceress meteor
was like gorgeous fire and lightning
once we got all the effects up and
running
uh that was definitely a couple of times
where we would be
just in a review and we're like oh like
and we 10 minutes would go by and we're
like oh
crap we had a meeting we were just
playing now um another thing that that
kind of goes without saying
that just because it's it's parody but
uh eight player multiplayer um that just
works but uh
once again it was it's tricky to get
that going so with
multiplayer are there going to be any
changes any differences in there
from pvp to trading to
how players interact you know units
blocking each other and i mean
all sorts of stuff so with multiplayer
uh we want to keep all the features
you've known and loved there so pvp will
still be there
down to like opening the party window
and engaging hostility
um trading is still gonna function the
same as you know
you know you can go into games trade
items or talk in chat channels and
things like that
areas of improvement though like i said
going back to my mentioning of
reimagining a lot of the ui
um improvements to the balance lobby um
so
we're trying to look at some things like
improving uh like how you browse
uh server games like so when you're
looking at a game to join
um and typing passwords and things like
that that's the kind of area we're
trying to see how we could smooth that
in ways like
um making sure you can browse uh normal
games nightmare games and hell games
even though you've graduated to
the higher difficulty i'm sure you've
known that there's nothing
nothing worse than accidentally killing
bail and nightmare when you're trying to
do nightmare bail runs and you're like
i can't find any of the games anymore
for nightmare bail runs
but you can if you log into a separate
character right you go to a separate
character and then look at
our logic right we want it we want we
saw since there are workarounds there
that that made it uh easier for us to
make the decision of allowing some of
those things
another change is also looking into uh
reducing ladder seasons overall so right
now ladder seasons in diablo 2 are six
months
and we're looking at reducing that as
well to help
uh have more engagement um and and
kind of drive more incentives too you
know six months is a long time um
and we're looking into like if if we
make it shorter we could probably
have greater beats throughout the year
as well as
seeing people strive harder for getting
like that to that level 99 right
so is there going to be any
reward change on that or will it just
simply be
you know the same standard you get to 99
you're
99 on that leaderboard and i mean that's
a giant reward in itself
but i don't know if there's any uh other
piece go up on the
battlenet website or something we're not
looking into adding
any thing beyond what the game really
did but in some ways there
there will be some things that kind of
come out of because of what we changed
so
we have the latter the leader board
right where you can see each class going
to level 99 they're easier ways to
filter through that
um and we're also looking into
saving that right so you can always look
back to previous
uh seasons as well so in a way we're
creating that kind of legacy now
that has kind of been dropped from the
past so that's that's one advantage is
kind of your names could be there in the
legacy if you're looking in the past
i mean i think that would be cool enough
just anything to
keep it there as like uh forever like
this was season one season two you know
like that's when i got mine tonight
because i know a lot of people like to
go and reflect
kind of on their old characters and
pushes and
stuff like that character exploration
will not be a thing anymore by the way
due to modern battle integrations you do
not have to you will not have to worry
about refreshing your character so they
will stay with you awesome
um will there be anything different with
like
character names then if that's the case
oh
yeah so this is one that we talked about
for a very very long time so
uh because we are moving to global
servers
and we have um cross progression
we will allow duplicate names
because with everyone being in the same
thing across
all consoles and all platforms and other
things like that you would very quickly
bump into duplicates
um like day one and so we are allowing
duplicate names however they will also
be
um appended with your your gamertag or
your battlenet id or other things like
that so that
you are still unique um but this also
allows us to get for people to play the
game quicker
because we can give you we can autofill
in your name um other things like that
rob touched on a little bit but another
mention there was
going to global servers as well so
this is a new thing we're doing where
the concept of u.s
west u.s east asia regions um
and eu are no longer going to be a thing
in terms of like um being on separated
servers so now
for the push for a global uh play
with with diablo 2 you can now be able
to join
across people around the world i think
that's a fantastic change that's always
been one of the like saddest parts is
like
they're on eu and i'm on you know us
east and then my other friends on us
west and it's like how do we get us all
together you know like
okay somebody has to make a sacrifice
there um
and so this is that seems like a really
positive change
so far you guys are killing it i'm
loving all i mean
absolutely i just want to say like i'm
loving all of the changes
and all the decisions that have been
made it feels like you're really
respecting the integrity of the game
but really bringing in a lot of that
quality of life
because diablo 2 just had some of those
pain points like
mule and separate servers and all of
that
um so i just i just want to throw that
out there really quick
there's a lot of yeah love and care
going on into this like
we're very passionate about diablo ii
you know
um i can even give you a little
anecdotes of um when i
started on on the team um
i was asking around too naturally as a
designer i want to know as much as
possible about this game
in order to make good decisions on it on
a remaster so
i asked around like what what kind of
files and leftover archives do we have
um
from from before from blizzard north and
uh i was told like i was given some
and like this i was told that was it um
which i quickly
disbelieved because i like to just
do my own little digging arounds to find
out things so i dug around a lot in a
lot of
archives and i looked around in
different teams as well because
naturally
a game from 20 years ago people have
moved on different teams and and like
where has data moved around across our
other games across blizzard
so it was it was within folders within
folders i like to say
that i found a lot of old
source files from diablo 2. a lot of
things like within folders of saying
stuff we should archive
and there was a lot of stuff to archive
indeed because there are a lot of things
like we're talking like uh
model source files old tools
uh that blizzard north used to create
like the sprites and things like that
all these things i i spent months and
months organizing and and
communicate that out to the team and
help getting blizzard library team and
other people to help out too
to help share as much information as
possible which
helps a lot with with when we're
adapting some of these
models and whatnot and making new new
art out of it because you know
sometimes those pixels aren't good
enough and if we have some kind of
source model to look at if we have it
now we can make even closer decisions on
that day when he found that i think that
really helped
like help me greatly like we sent all
that imagery
even the models i think we sent over to
um to the outsource teams and different
art teams
um which they used as like a stepping
stone
the only only piece of art we actually
reused one to one
um were tyriel's wings so he took this
we actually took the material wings from
the old
uh max file and then just repurposed
that for
for hours like we did very little work
very little modernization of that we
just made it work
um but yeah we did follow a lot of the
rules that um
the old game actually used for like uh
another example is the
uh the succubus the succubus and witch i
think the old
the old blizzard north model they reuse
the assassin mesh
for for the body and we do the same
thing we use our assassin mess for the
for the succubus yeah a lot of fun
discoveries that we're actually kind of
making the same decisions on in
interesting ways
another example too like is uh find like
because we found
a lot of stuff uh there's a lot of old
texture files for
some environments on the game so another
example is like
the walls you see in the act ii tombs um
with those kinds of like
paintings on them are the same or the
same textures we're using because we
found
the source files for those any symbology
we we have questions on
we always like jump into that archive
try to find some kind of source or
reference or something and
we just reuse it as much as possible we
want this to be as true as as possible
that could even carry over the
cinematics too you know like a lot of
the cinematics cover the same locations
think of like talrash's tomb
with bale in front of it and there's all
those runes going on behind them finding
sources like that to try to match as
much as possible was a goal and
i'm glad to say we did find those kinds
of things and they're matching it very
well so it's helping our cinematics too
there was even concepts we we repurposed
like we found a couple concepts that
were
were amazing from you know 20 years ago
um the blood hawk and the blood hawk
nest
and we use that completely to rebuild
our new asset
i mean that's fascinating i feel like i
could just sit here for
hours and hours days if you guys talk
through every single thing you found in
the source files
i could do i'm still organizing it to
this day i
could find something that could work
because i put it i'm very meticulous
with this stuff because i love it so
much you know i'm
i'm putting like categorizing everything
like this is everything i found on war
eve this is everything i found on
on the greater mummy monster or bail or
something and then
if if chris comes to me and needs help
with like some kind of uh
way of identifying what parts of the
creatures are something i even go
through lengths of like seeing if i
could open up those models
um and actually render like re-rendering
them out in a way that we could actually
see
it in higher detail and like you know
see like what
like oh the greater mummy is showing
like part of his bone on his knee so we
should try to match that or something
like that and there's a lot of
interesting stories and references that
we actually used to create the new art
by re-rendering models out to see
everything yeah it was literally like
video game archaeology and even learning
how
parts of d1 were made parts of the code
that were commented out
totally geek out on just all of the you
know because it's
it's it's a game that we all kind of
grew up in a lot of us
got into the games industry because of
these types of games and this game
particular right like
yeah and so we it's almost like we're
treating like a classic car
right like okay it probably shouldn't
run on leaded gas anymore
but you really can't change it right you
just got to make it
you know good enough uh even better you
know than they remember
and uh good for another 20 years yeah
and even like you know mention of diablo
one is very key too like
we look at diablo one as well because
naturally this being a sequel to diablo
one
especially within the time span of when
it came like like diablo one you know
was 1996 and diablo 2000
a lot of things carried over um
throughout development so
going back to see diablo one and what
it's like also helped
us uh make decisions even some of the
arts too because like we discovered
certain things we didn't even realize
before
until later down the line like an
example is in the chaos sanctuary
you see a lot of statues um with these
black knights and those are actually the
same
chaos nights you see in diablo one so
like sometimes
some of the things i find even source
files from diablo one were useful
for us for reference so we can make the
new statues and things like that
even the uh the sorcerer and the act
three hireling
shared very similar models like it was
just a an addition an
addition helmet or a little bit of
detail on the chest but that was really
the difference you guys need to do
a just like developer archaeology
discussion at some point where you just
sit down and talk through all of this
because this is like the most
fascinating stuff i've heard i mean i've
played so much diablo too that i know so
many intricacies
of the game but like when
there's like more to be discovered it's
like oh man i'm like
itching to know so the funny thing is
like you know
going back to our like core philosophies
on the game like you know we wanted
to keep discovery and in the mystery and
stuff we
because you keep discovering things all
the time when you play diablo 2.
like all these little hidden rules and
informations it kind of
it kind of carries that fascination over
through development as well like we find
a lot of things in the code design
documents models things like that that
were really fascinating to see like how
they were made and i i learned something
new every day on the projects
one thing shifting back to the online
play here
i know there's definitely gonna be
questions around security
how are we handling duping how are we
handling bots how are we handling
uh you know just anything around that
round downs and all of the disconnects
and
all of that good stuff that we deal with
online
what's being taken uh or what actions
being taken there
so moving over to modern battlenet helps
us with a lot of those
types of things um to say it's
you know lock tight that i i wouldn't
dare do that that's like throwing a
gauntlet down to the community
to try to break it but all of that
should be far more secure now
now we do still allow you to play
offline
right um you will need to authenticate
that your copy is legit but after that
you won't be bothered and so there's a
reason why we leave those
characters quarantined away from online
i mean yeah we have we have a server
team
working on it and these are some of
their efforts right we want to we want
to
stop the bots stop duping um as much as
possible there's a lot of
strides happening in the back end of
things so
i'm excited to play this game and i'm
sure a lot of other people are very
excited
how can we sign up for this closed beta
and when will this game be coming out
actually we will be doing a technical
alpha and you can sign up on our web
page
today for future waves of invites as for
the game itself it will be releasing
2021.
well i just want to say thank you to the
remastering team right here i absolutely
am blown away
by how much effort and how much passion
you guys are putting into this game and
and just into diablo 2.
i've loved diablo 2 for 20 years and
i never thought that the game could get
better but
i think you guys are respecting the
integrity while
upgrading and adding and improving and i
think this is going to overall just
better the game so thank you guys so
much i appreciate you having me on
and for all of the hard work you've done
awesome thank you i mean your praise
means
the world to us i mean you're you and
people like you who keep the game going
um for for 20 years like that's
if you guys didn't do that this might
not be happening right
we see the passion um in what you do
and what your your colleagues do like so
thank you even more
and thanks for coming to do this this
was fun
[Music]
not even them
[Music]
you